hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nights at [ __ ] boys
now before you say anything I need to
preface this this game was absurdly
requested soon after it came out after
the first five nights at Freddy's came
out and it's been requested non-stop
since and I've avoided it because I
thought it was going to be stupid but I
recently asked Wade it was played both
the first and the second one if it was
worth playing and he said yes so I
didn't just take his word for it I asked
on Facebook for you guys's opinion on
whether I should play it or not you guys
said yes absolutely play away it's a
fantastic very crude very absurd very
offensive game but apparently it's fun
and one commenter in particular said the
experience would be enhanced if I added
alcohol to the equation so that's
exactly what I'm gonna do when I play
this game and I'm gonna play it all in
one sitting here today all at once at
the beginning of every episode I'm going
to take a shot of that delicious
cinnamon whisky that got me Bob wait
Jack and yamimash in trouble in possum
at PAX East not that much trouble don't
ask we're not gonna tell but either way
I want to preface I'm 25 years old I've
had a lot of drinking experience I'm
practically a professional don't try
this at home this game is not for
kiddies if you're a child or under the
age of something that's influential ask
your parents before watching this series
because it's going to get loud crude and
offensively rude all right so I got a
clever little skull shot glasses here
I'm cracking this open for the first
time so you didn't think I just put food
coloring in water that's the good stuff
well I mean I don't know if it's the
good stuff definitely not good for you
it's just yet I gotta remember that this
is a longer game like I think Wade
played nine parts of this so here's to a
good time playing five nights of [ __ ]
boys first shot down the hatch cheers
everybody
yeah oh man that's good also dry should
mention drunk minecraft is that big flip
today but it's going to be filmed later
this weekend and we're gonna have drunk
my graphs all right bye full of people
on Instagram for that would you like to
login I would absolutely not I don't
want to standard harder impossible I
guess I should try with standard because
I've heard that this game is actually
kind of hard but I'm probably gonna miss
out on some stuff if I don't do it on
any higher Freddy fazbear's pizza
Freddy wants to have a hardcore night of
debauchery but to do so he
[ __ ] on all the go okay never mind why
must I [ __ ] I don't know Freddie but I'm
Freddie okay I guess this game that's
actually kind of adorable oh so clever
oh this is going to be a great game
isn't it oh I can't wait good Krunk
indeed Freddie oh man oh Alpha Party had
a beard freddie was surprised what
that doesn't make oh okay oh oh yes that
hurts a lot okay so scream skills so
it's legitimately an RPG like this is
legitimately oh oh they're gonna kill me
I know I think I'm gonna make it just
out just in time
crap I'm glad I didn't decide to be die
every time I die
take a shot route which is something
that I thought of doing Wow okay thank
you cranky
yes son of a [ __ ] I just started
playing the game I'm not ready to do
this I didn't even get a chance to save
this is a bunch of bull oh what a piece
of crap I'm glad I didn't try hard mode
what the hell
get good and join today please please
please Freddie Freddie want some action
in his night of debauchery so what the
hell was I supposed to do did the party
hats on the did the party hats on the
table is like no no I'm not ready for
that I'm supposed to [ __ ] on the camera
but I couldn't even beat a party hat how
do you expect me to beat anything else I
need to recruit my booze absolutely and
you want to want to forsake any of that
because you're just the manliest bear in
the woods whoa okay I got you
oh so
well this Oh God no babe the party ants
I couldn't even beat the alpha party ATS
why guess the beta would be better than
okay
Pizza I'm ready for Freddy you actually
played gaming things drunk in a long
time I'm not drunk yeah God no no God no
no that's not the kookie kookie kookie
kookie klu klux klan that's nothing yeah
I know
no dammit this is going to suck balls
big robot balls all day long because I
know what I'm gonna be doing I'm gonna
be be hammered and trying to farm kills
while I'm doing everything else and
success and horribly for me okay so
whatever I know what I need to do I just
need to go I guess over here maybe over
here it's gonna be a loser okay
oh one I can beat up one I can beat up
one so good I'm level two oh whoa hey
hello friend would you like to buy
things
maybe where'd you come from oh yeah
alright okay so small pizza shield a
pizza still made out of a [ __ ] pizza
oh man okay sure why not I can buy it I
might as well I need everything that I
possibly can is so weird
Oh so weird
this is so weird it's like a legitimate
thing why is this a legitimate thing
they say got a microphone ooh enhance my
scream I'm assuming I'm gonna assemble
I know these are these are the different
frequencies or speeds at which the
scream that they come in your face oh
not not like that geez don't don't take
this the wrong way did I mention that
this whole series was gonna be a night
of debauchery
well good there was a good collaboration
but at least I have a chance to get my
buddy Bonnie back on my side what okay
so now I gotta go find Barney's head
somehow Tommy headed yeah I hate my
friends apparently cheese tonight can I
engage those party hats oh this is gonna
be random okay just one at a time please
I need to level up very much so didn't
hurt at all I got my pizza shield Scott
crust filled with flavor and defense all
right good
now level three I have no idea if I'm
supposed to set aside time to actually
grind or if I actually need to be
worried about anything else and where do
I save do I save at this place where
apparently I worship Satan oh I can save
any time okay that's good yeah a little
horn that's so adorable all right what
do I do
I probably don't wanna go down these
halls because he's probably where the
high level areas is so if the other area
was just where one was shown and this
area is where I could fight one to two
then I kinda need to stay in this area
Oh foxy are you my bro are you my beau
bro bro
I had no idea foxy come on
a party hat already for a beta how am I
gonna do Cameron thank you
I'm out of here I'm not ready for a
gamma cuz I know my Greek alphabet
just like the fraternity party said all
that Freddie to go to I don't know where
am I gonna find Bonnie's head you have
mommy's head oh I talk a lot about
inhaling my dog I don't even wanna know
about Freddy fazbear's dung I don't
think anyone wants to know about Freddy
fazbear's dog okay Dwight I know I have
to okay I'm thinking I just have to
level up a bit which means I'm gonna
have to kill things one shotted I'm
getting better at things
am i level three yet okay I'm gonna be
right back I'm gonna level up a bit oh
cool I can buy skills okay I didn't know
this before okay now get all Freddy
skills great that's good for me I know
how to RPG real good level five but I
still don't have any goddamn health this
is another way to heal that I don't know
which I would assume like some rest
point or something
okay so what am I trying to do is I'm
gonna try to defeat this first camera
because it seems to be the easiest
difficulty so let's see what happens
because I actually have my skill so I'm
gonna [ __ ] all over it as Freddy wanted
me to do for some strange reason engage
top hat I'm supposed to be doing
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] come on
[Music]
good good I was trying to get good how
much have I suppose a farm if I can't
get good enough to beat that I need to
get Bonnie that's what I need to do I
need to find out a way to get Bonnie on
I got ahead here dammit
oh good just one of you [ __ ] why do
you hurt so bad
god damn it just die oh you sack of crap
oh jeez okay there we go
oh man you only give twice the
experience of two other party ads this
is such [ __ ] this bathroom is a
bathroom of death should I walk in on
foxy masturbating again or should I
actually do something with my life good
attitude Freddy you try that who's gonna
work you didn't try it hard enough you
dick
ah I just gotta find Bonnie's freaking
head maybe he's over here Barney lighter
[Music]
[Laughter]
why did I touch the party hat on the
ground I knew it was gonna be bad but
I'm just a dingus damn it and a
dumb-dumb and a diddly-doo in the dongey
donger mm-hmm
but I can probably still go get the
lighter got it and then I go back so
it's gotta be something else in these
places it would be good for me to get
dum de dum dum you are dumbest goodbye I
have the lighter okay oh I get it okay
so the Balloon Boy Yelp oh that's death
straight-up death over there
so the Balloon Boy yell was Balloon Boy
somehow managed to take my lighter from
me after I got it I didn't know that was
supposed to burn the [ __ ] to the
ground how much you give me Oh for you
today fine item friend it will cost
fifteen tokens whatever [ __ ] off but you
gotta be so mean okay so now I have the
lighter and I can burn Foxy's tent to
the frickin ground
whoa well that was rather explosive he
was just trying to masturbate in the era
I mean half the internet thinks Foxy's a
girl anyway why you got to interrupt him
like that doesn't make any sense
and that was earthbound music right
there which I like that such that's a
good touch that's a nice touch so now I
got foxy with me so I mean that might be
twice as strong
probably oh hey foxy you're not creepy
at all whatever can we beat him just be
me and foxy probably not I'm out of here
cuz I know I know there's got to be some
way that uh I can find Bonnie easily
because he's got to be relatively
obvious if this is not that obvious yeah
I'm gonna give this I'm gonna find this
I'm gonna figure this out okay foxy
strong
there's only level one he's already
photography well good to have a mom I
said I imagine this would be weird like
the final kitchen key oh I'm making so
much progress I mean how much could I
possibly do more than what I'm doing
right now
I imagine anyway so now I got that maybe
I'll be able to find Bonnie's head
chicken in the oven
oh you sassy sue don't tempt me
oh I could have gotten down there got
that any time well this is just a sack
of [ __ ] I don't even know where Oh now
they have chica she can go in the female
bathroom and that means I could probably
get like maybe uh maybe like his yeah
Tommy its you tiga are you stuck on a
loop there chica maybe later we'll bake
it a little Valerie but not now okay so
now she just doesn't have to touch that
thing
okay Bonnie's head voucher head voucher
what saving me oh I got to go back to
Balloon Boy again for some stupid reason
all right cool believe me Oh to fight
the other oh okay but I'm not now well
actually now that I got my whole party
here I can probably kick the crap out of
all of you I don't have any other skills
the other one foxy like that wow they
are all really weak oh god damn you guys
suck so much ass why are they so weak is
it like their skills that they need or
is it just because they haven't leveled
up yet to level seven and for some
reason they're not doing as much damage
which is baloney like what would it be
like that oh I guess there's no
anticipation of when I would have been
able to get them to join my party so
therefore it wouldn't have been doll
that interesting oh they leveled up a
league level four already
okay well nevermind that's good all
problems have been solved then I don't
need to worry about anything else at all
hey yeah give me your special item
inhale the dong wait no well that
doesn't make any sense if I'm supposed
to let me just buy the skills for
everyone else oh come on you got to put
Bonnie first I know what I'm doing here
yes I know yes I know inhaling dongs
that's very good for you rush down cuz I
imagine chicas just gonna be the healer
of the group if that's a thing that
happens here okay speed you know that
means okay thank you
what are you talking about I got a
voucher I don't know where to turn in
the voucher how do I turn in a voucher
what even is a what am I gonna do I have
an idea okay so I think I need to go
back in there I need to fight the Hat in
here cuz that's gonna open up another
hole in the wall and that's how the
other dude appeared so if I fight this
guy I did not heal up the rest of them
that's good anyway because I didn't need
to okay foxy you got oh I guess that's
cool
Pizza pass - Wow a thousand that's a
great heal I feel so buffed cool real
RPG [ __ ] going on here okay so now
you're gonna gang up on this guy it's
gonna be real good there you go I need
to go upgrade their equipment too
because I haven't done that yet it's the
total ridiculousness before and then
here is just nuts for no reason because
it's an actual RPG and real things are
happening here okay thank you Balloon
Boy yes I would do you have a special
there you go
you have a voucher I have for you some
fine friggin now I can go get Bonnie 9
go get Barney now Bonnie's gonna join my
party and then I'm gonna have a fun time
beating a camera into the ground not you
yes but while I'm here I might as well
buy you know the cupcakes that's good
okay more tacky dues for my peeps my
awesome peeps Oh
blam legit RPG crap I'm doing here why
am I doing this bunch of bull I want
another shot that's what I want to know
yes Thank You Bonnie thank you
another party member okay well man what
else are we supposed to do I mean I'm
assuming we're supposed to [ __ ] on all
the cameras but why why is that a thing
I mean can I even go down to the lake
the Security office and talk to Mike
it's Mike available is my gonna be right
around the corner oh I need to level up
Bunch how's Bonnie starting out solo
when Bonnie was like the first person I
interacted but the last person I could
get I think I just need to power level
for a little bit because my crews a
little low here so excuse me for a
second okay I think I'm doing pretty
good because I got a lot of tokens I'm
just gonna get Bonnie's equipment up to
snuff and then we're gonna be able to
move forward yes I know wait is the
other balloon boy does the other balloon
boy have better equipment than this
balloon boy here because he had that
special offer but I don't know oh it
probably does because I have fought
harder dude therefore it makes sense if
I could fight a hard whatever that
didn't make it goddamn sense at all
yeah it's true it's true it's true okay
so Balloon Boy was a guitar like yes let
me get it for Freddie because he
obviously needs this [ __ ] oh they can
all have beat shields I got two for now
that's good enough for me I guess all
right it's cool it's cool it's cool okay
so on my equipment saw up to snuff and
I'm actually ready to get going here I'm
just gonna play for a little bit longer
than I'm gonna in the episode because I
want to find out where I need to go next
before I find out if I'm ready to do
what I own Oh what I know what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna end this episode by
fighting this new you real gonna be like
legitimately oh wait no [ __ ] whatever
yeah whatever just straight up go for it
there's gonna be a long fight oh boy
long and boring and full of copyrighted
music that I'm gonna have to edit out
later all right
Oh foxy at the killing blow there and
the camera gets [ __ ] all over with robot
[ __ ] and ye be not wanting robot [ __ ] in
your face o only a thousand G's gonna
fall like well it is currently because
it's covered in it and why did you want
to do that anyway I mean once I kill
everything in the air there's not gonna
be able to way to see because we're
obviously looking at a camera right now
or something like that
I don't know also is there like a bed I
could sleep in or in
alright gonna recover everything could
they just all have a big gangbang up on
top of the pile
you know big orgy and just have fun
there No okay fine then so thank you
everybody so much for watching I hope
you're enjoying five nights at [ __ ] boys
god this game is just we got damn dick
Ulis but hey in the next episode I'm
gonna be another shot in I'm gonna be
just a little bit more tipsy and then
we're gonna have a lot more fun so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
look forward to the next episode like
tomorrow or something
[Music]
I didn't